Apple has officially set September 10th
as the date for their upcoming iPhone
event so what should we expect to see
from them yes you should absolutely
expect that but what else last year's
event focused solely on the Apple watch
in the iPhone so should we expect
anything different well Apple has titled
this event by innovation only which
shows that we should expect some pretty
awesome changes contrary to the belief
that Apple is planning only minor spec
updates for the iPhone in the Apple
watch but before we talk about these two
devices I want to first mention that
we'll definitely see the release of all
of Apple's new software like iOS 13 and
Mac OS Catalina and unlike last year
Apple is expected to release two brand
new subscription services Apple TV plus
a streaming service with original shows
and movies and Apple arcade a game
subscription service with over a hundred
new games we expect Apple to finally
announce more details including the
pricing and release date for both of
them and because of these two services
we may actually see a brand new Apple
device more on that in just a minute but
let's first get into the Apple watch
series 5 last year's series 4 was a
seriously good update and it's hard to
imagine how else Apple could innovate
with the Apple watch since we haven't
seen very many leaks just yet but here's
what we know and expect so far the
physical design will more than likely
stay the same with expected changes like
a new processor with improved battery
life and new health features like the
possibility of blood pressure monitoring
coming to the series 5 there were some
talks about Apple switching to a micro
LED display which would lead to better
battery life and the possibility of an
always-on display since micro LED is
less acceptable to burn in but a lot of
publications are expecting that to come
on the series 6 Apple watch not the
series 5 also a couple of icons leaked
from inside the beta of watch OS 6
showing that we should expect a ceramic
model and for the first time ever a
titanium casing now whether that'll be
part of the expensive Edition models or
if it will replace the stainless steel
casing we're not really sure moving on
to the iPhones three new iPhone 11
models are coming as well with at least
one of them being branded as the iPhone
11 pro now if they're in
using the pro branding they're
definitely gonna have to include some
really innovative changes so here's what
we expect first off it's gonna pack the
a13 processor which should see a great
boost in performance especially for
graphics and there are also rumors of a
new AMX or Matrix coprocessor which
should help improve augmented reality
processing we're also expecting the pro
model to be focused on major camera
improvements with everything from higher
resolution sensors even better video
recording performance and features a new
ultra wide lens the possibility of a new
raw photo mode and much more but we're
also expecting a new smart camera
feature which actually snaps a photo
with all three cameras at the same time
and uses artificial intelligence to let
you switch lenses while editing and post
as well as allowing you to perfectly
adjust the crop without affecting the
depth of field or blur this is something
that will completely change the
photography game along with that don't
expect Apple to get rid of the knotch
that'll most likely happen next year but
the upcoming iPhone is rumored to come
with a new multi angle face ID sensor
that'll be much more reliable and work
while it's laying flat on a table and
finally if it's getting the pro branding
there's a slight chance that it'll
borrow a couple of Pro features from the
iPad pro like the USB C port and 120
Hertz Pro motion technology for the
display
you should definitely expect a new 18
watt fast charger bundled in the box and
now let's talk about the possibility of
a brand new Apple device because the
Apple TV Plus and Apple arcade
subscription services are coming Apple
needs a better way to make them easily
available to the masses of course
they'll be available on iOS and Mac OS
devices but if you want to use them on
your TV you have to buy the Apple TV and
the HD model costs a hundred and fifty
dollars more than most people would like
to pay for it and the 4k model is many
times better at only thirty dollars more
so my personal speculation is that Apple
is gonna release a brand new and much
cheaper Apple TV dongle that plugs into
a TV's HDMI port similar to chromecast
or Amazons fire TV stick it should be
priced between 60 and $100 so it'll give
people a much cheaper option to access
Apple TV Plus and Apple arcade on their
TVs and it'll probably replace the $150
Apple TV
HD alongside that we can expect a brand
new serie TV remote possibly with gaming
features built-in and if this new TV
streaming device is coming it'll most
certainly support PlayStation Xbox and
MFI controllers for use with apple
arcade and it's not pure speculation
either since we saw rumors about an
Apple TV dongle last year other than
that you shouldn't really expect
anything else from the September event
there is the possibility of a new home
pod Mini or perhaps a beat
smart home speaker but we may not hear
about that until next year new updated
iPad pros a 10-point two inch regular
iPad in a 16 inch macbook pro are all
expected to come this year but most
likely not until Apple's October event
so don't get your hopes up apple's 2019
mac pro is also coming this fall but the
release date will most likely be in
either October or November but whatever
happens we're definitely getting our
hands on the new iPhones Apple watches
and basically every other Apple device
that's coming so if you're not already
subscribed click that circle above so
you don't miss out our nerve reviews and
comparison videos thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next one
[Applause]